LIZ FONG-JONES: Hi there.
My name is Liz.
And I am an SRE teaching
Google Cloud customers
how to build and operate
reliable services.
SETH VARGO: And I'm Seth, a
Developer Advocate focused
on infrastructure
and operations.
In the previous episode,
we discussed SLOs and error
budgets as a means of balancing
availability and new feature
development.
In this episode, Liz
and I discuss toil.
So Liz, from what
I understand, toil
is just work that
I don't like to do,
so emails, meetings,
commuting to work.
So what can I do
to reduce my toil?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Hold
on a second, Seth.
Those things aren't
specifically toil.
So we call those
things "overhead,"
because they are things
that are not directly tied
to a production service.
So they're just a requirement
of any office, job really.
Most people at the
company, not just SREs,
have to do expense
reports and so forth.
And that's not really toil.
SETH VARGO: OK, so if toil
isn't just work that I don't
like to do, what is it, then?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Toil's
the kind of work
that's tied to running a
production service that
tends to be manual, repetitive,
automatable, tactical,
and devoid of long-term value.
Additionally, toil
tends to scale linearly
as the service grows.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So each time an operator needs
to touch a production system,
that represents some toil time.
But what if I codify all of the
times that I need to touch it,
and I just run a script
instead of manually
running the commands?
LIZ FONG-JONES: You've
reduced the amount
of toil you have to do, but
you haven't made it not toil.
Because you still have to run
that script every single time
the system requires
an intervention.
So that still is manual.
And it gets even worse the
larger your service grows,
because you have
to keep doing it
over and over and over again.
SETH VARGO: OK.
And you also said
something-- the task
has to be repetitive, too.
So if I just do it
maybe once or twice,
is that still toil or no?
LIZ FONG-JONES: That
is probably not toil,
at least the first or
second time, or at least
it's not toil that's
worth automating.
You really want to automate
toil when it gets to the point
that you're doing it
three or four times,
or where you are taking hours
and hours out of your day.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So if a task can be
automated, it probably
should be automated.
What about things that are
pretty common in operations,
like pager alerts?
LIZ FONG-JONES: So pager
alerts are almost always toil,
because of the fact that
they are interrupt driven
and they're reactive.
You don't know when
it's going to happen.
And it just swallows a
bunch of your time just
to get the system back
to where it was before.
SETH VARGO: OK, so what if
I get paged in the middle
of the night to provision
additional capacity
for a service?
So I look through the system,
and I realize that the only way
to do this is manually.
I have to click buttons.
I have to run commands.
So I do that.
I get the service
back up and running.
And I go back to sleep.
And in the morning, I
wake up, and I realize
that I need to automate this.
So I spent about six or seven
hours building some automation
so that the service can scale
automatically in the future.
That's a lot of toil.
How do we account for that?
LIZ FONG-JONES: Not
quite, because of the fact
that the time that you spent
during the middle of the night,
between when you
got paged and when
the system returned to normal
from your manual action,
that's toil.
However, the latter part of
what you did during the day--
that's a worthwhile
project that actually
reduces the toil over
time, because the toil has
no enduring value.
But the automation
that you do in order
to reduce the amount of toil
you do, that's real useful work.
SETH VARGO: I see.
And I think it's clear now
why you've coined a new term
to define this type of work.
There's always going to be
tasks that you don't want
to do, like overhead,
like email, and meetings,
and commuting, and
expense reports.
And there's always going to be
kind of operationally grungy
tasks, like restarting
services, that
are devoid of long-term value.
So they aren't actually
toil in certain cases.
In previous episodes, we talked
about how everything in SRE
is measured, though.
So how do we measure toil?
LIZ FONG-JONES: So there are
two ways that we measure toil.
First of all, we try
to concentrate the toil
into blocks, for instance,
during your on-call week,
so you don't get
pages and tickets off
of your on-call week.
So it makes it a lot
easier to measure
when it is toil,
when it is not toil.
Additionally, we have people
track their toil time,
sometimes by sampling.
And we send quarterly
surveys to make sure
that people understand how much
of their time is spent on toil.
Do they feel like
they have more room?
And then toil is also
everyone's responsibility.
So we'll often ask the product
development software engineers
to measure their
amount of toil as well,
to make sure that we're
spending everyone's time well.
SETH VARGO: So you
mentioned that the goal
should be to reduce toil.
Shouldn't the goal be to
eliminate toil entirely?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Part of the problem
with eliminating toil entirely
is that there are often tasks
that are not worth automating.
If you spend an hour
fixing something by hand,
and it happens maybe
three times a year,
but it would take you 10
hours to write the automation,
that's going to have a
very long payoff threshold.
Whereas if you have something
that's firing all the time,
you might want to go and
get it out of your way.
So as you reduce
the amount of toil
and leave alone the things
that are not worth automating,
you'll find that there's
some amount of toil
associated with each service.
You can keep the
total amount of toil
you do somewhere between
30% and 50% of your time,
and spend the rest of your time
doing worthwhile projects that
reduce the toil, so
that over time, you
can accept more responsibility
for more services,
or your service can just
naturally grow in size
and have your amount of
work really remain constant.
SETH VARGO: I see.
So SREs get to
spend at least half,
if not two thirds of their time
working on real engineering
work.
The SRE stands for Site
Reliability Engineering.
So they get to focus on
things like improving
reliability, performance,
utilization, monitoring.
And all of those
things can actually
reduce toil in the
future as well.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Yes.
That's exactly correct.
And also, we share
our best practices.
So when we do these
items of research
into how we make
our services better,
we can often apply them across
multiple different SRE teams.
So we'll publish white
papers within the company
or on our blog, describing to
SREs how they might make sure
that their toil stays
low and within budget,
so that we can spend more time
making our services better
in the long term.
At the end of the day, the E
in SRE stands for Engineering.
And engineering
work is really what
lets our organization
scale, and meet
the demands of all of the
applications and services
and machines that we support.
SETH VARGO: Great.
This has been really helpful.
And I think I have a much
better understanding of toil
and its negative consequences.
LIZ FONG-JONES: But toil isn't
always entirely negative.
Sometimes, it's
worthwhile to have
some amount of predictable
and automatable work
for individual people
to cut their teeth on.
For instance, let's suppose
that you have someone new
to your team that
wants to learn how
does the system actually work
before you put them on call.
Well, you might have them
poke around at the system
manually in order to fix
something that you already
had lying around.
Also, it's really
helpful to have things
that people feel satisfied
by doing, where they
get an immediate reward,
rather than working
at a product for the long term
and not necessarily knowing
when it's going to finish.
So sometimes, it's
helpful for people
to do those tasks
in the short term.
But we don't think it's
a good idea for people
to focus entirely on doing toil,
because that doesn't really
advance the engineering
part of their job,
and it can cause career
stagnation and unhappiness
in the long term.
SETH VARGO: So toil
and toil budgets
do not have a direct relation
to the DevOps pillars
that we've discussed
in previous episodes.
But they do closely
influence the desire
to measure everything and
reduce organizational silence.
By giving operators a
quantitative measurement,
toil and toil budgets
ensure a balance
between administering the
system and improving it.
This has really helped a lot.
I think it's a lot
clearer now why
we say that cost SRE
implements DevOps.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Thank you
everyone for watching.
Don't forget to
subscribe to the channel.
And also stay tuned for
our next video, where
we discuss how Google teaches
SRE practices to customers
through the Customer
Reliability Engineering Program.